I said I'm gonna come greetings appease
welcome to the DS Show subscribe if you
haven't already we got a question that
we're gonna go ahead and answer about
the belief system in Islam regarding the
New Testament the Old Testament because
as Muslims we believe not only in the
one God the angels that were sent who
were filled these books that God
revealed throughout time II of the torah
and the injeel are those in existence
today do Muslims believe that the New
Testament is actually then geo many
people have many misconceptions about
this and we're going to go ahead and
stretch answer these misconceptions with
a former Christian and the author of the
injeel and the bible john Fonteyn let's
take it to him
i said i went across to LA how you doing
brother Eddie yeah thank you for the
question thanks for joining me here in
Uganda now regarded a question what is
the Islamic position in terms of the
Bible now first of all we know that the
Quran is the final revelation sent from
Allah and within the Quran our law tells
us that he actually revealed books
previously to the Quran to different
nations now in the hadith the Prophet
people told us that there were over
124,000 prophets a sense of humanity
throughout time and 315 of them were
actually messengers now a messenger is a
prophet who receives a new revelation a
new law now amongst these messengers
many of them are actually mentioned in
the Quran 25 and them by name and Allah
also tells us about five of the books
five of the books actually mentioned by
name in the Quran the first one being
the sawed off of ibrahim the torah given
to moses there's a ball given to Jesus
to given to David peace be upon him the
injeel given to jesus and finally the
coin which was sent to the prophet
muhammad sallallaahu solemn so it's very
clear in the quran that allah sent
messenger messengers two different
messengers throughout time now these
messages were the direct revel
and sent from Allah given to the
messengers okay these were not authored
by the messengers they were not offered
by the Companions of the messengers and
neither were they authored by scholars
these were direct books direct
revelations which were sent and given to
the prophets and they were the kitab
allah the book sent from Allah the Kalam
Allah the word the speech of Allah sent
and given to the prophets now when we
look at the modern-day Bible the
modern-day Bible is actually a
collection of books which are authored
by people you know that using the
Christians they tell us that they claim
that the first five books of the Bible
are authored by Moosa okay that they
claimed that the the psalms is offered
by many many different people some of
them offered by their claim dude
some of them offered by Korah and Asaf
and the New Testament they claim is a
collection of writings offered after
Jesus was raised to Allah you know after
Jesus was raised from the earth you know
these books were offered by people such
as Matthew Mark Luke and John and Paul
speaking about Jesus does that make
sense so there's a clear difference
between the Islamic perspective of the
books which was sent down which was the
toriel as a boy in injeel and the the
christian perspective of the modern-day
bible which is a collection of ceará is
a collection of biographies written by
human beings about the prophets so if
the Islamic position the correct
position of our position regarding the
Bible is that it's it's not from Allah
okay this is openly offered by people
now although the Bible is not revelation
okay it can't be revelation because it
can't be traced back to Allah or any of
its messengers there's still things in
the Bible that are true you know for
instance he speaks of moosa part in the
sea he speaks of ASA performing miracles
but just because these things agree with
Islam it doesn't it does not make it
revelation similarly to how we have many
hadith that are not authentic and we
have you know we don't regard them as
revelation simply because they agree
with Islam so there's there's a there's
a clear difference between the Islamic
perspective of
the previous books and the Christian
Jewish perspective as the modern-day
Jewish and Christian perspective of the
Bible often this is misunderstood
because of course the Jewish the Jews
and the Christians they claim and they
label parts of the Bible the Torah the
first five books of the Bible they they
labeled the Torah
some Jews label the Ten Commandments the
Torah some Christians and Jews labeled
the whole Old Testament the Torah and
even the Jews claimed the Talmud is a
part of the Torah so they're not clear
they're not very clear on what they mean
by the Torah but there is been some
confusion amongst the Muslims because
the Jews and Christians claim that they
have the Torah
you know many Muslims have presumed that
they have the actual Torah sent from
Moses but they don't have this today
they have a collection of writings by
people what's interesting even within
these writings if we go to the the
writings of the Old Testament it
actually speaks of Moosa going up the
mountain receiving the revelation but
but it doesn't actually claim to be that
revelation our question is where is that
Torah you know it doesn't exist today
the same happens with with the with the
New Testament you know the confusion has
come around because the the Arab
Christians they say that they believe in
the injeel so many muslims take them on
face value thinking that they actually
believe in an NGO sent from allah when
in reality what they mean by injeel is
the New Testament Gospels and the
writings of Paul you know the New
Testament the New Testament so because
they labeled the New Testament the
injeel this has given some confusion as
to what the christian is actually
believing but currently on the earth
today
there's no christian who believes in an
NGO that was sent from Allah given to
ISA as a book these people no longer
exists there were some Christians around
at the time of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu lives solemn such as salman
al-farsi
you know such as water could be now for
they were Christians they were true
followers of Jesus okay and they did
believe in an actual injeel and Hum Dil
are these these people actually embraced
Islam similarly we have the likes of a
delivering salaam who was one of the
chief rabbis in in medina also he
believed in an inner torah and he was
what actually waiting for a prophet to
come in medina and of course he embraced
islam so there's a lot of confusion
amongst muslims and christians but the
matter is very clear and simple
you know the islamic perspective is
books that were sent down and the
christian perspective is books which are
authored by people the the the the
christians and jews who originally
believed in the the islamic perspective
of the torah' injeel' they came when to
enter the fold of islam if we look at
the whole of Arabia the Middle East you
know all these Christians who who you
know actually many of them embraced
Islam and come under the fold of islam
al hamdulillah so I hope that was of
some benefit we must be very careful
when we're speaking about this subjects
because it is a part of our belief as
the prophets although he mentioned you
know the six pillars of Islam you know
the six pillars of a man I should say
you know being the belief in Allah the
angels the books the prophets the
judgement day and the belief their
angels the Judgment Day and the belief
in the divine decree you know so the
belief in the books is is is a very
important topic we must understand what
exactly what we believe and also what we
don't believe and we must be very
careful not to conflate the two you know
this is often a topic that is
misunderstood soul brother Eddie I hope
that was of some benefit and I'd like to
go back to you at the studio and I hope
to see you soon said I want a craft
Allah